We have some breaking news
because we are following.
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis announcing
we are learning
he is going to announce his 2024
presidential campaign with Elon Musk.
And we have Jessica Dean
who is on the line to tell us
what she is learning about this.
Just what can you tell us.
Hi, guys.
Good afternoon
well we're getting news it's
been of course
anticipated for many, many months now
but now it's official.
A spokesperson for Governor Ron
DeSantis, his political team
confirming to me
that he will announce
his 2024 presidential campaign
tomorrow night in a conversation
with the owner of Twitter.
Brianna as you mentioned, Elon Musk.
We are told
this will take place on Twitter spaces.
The site's users can participate
in audio conversations.
It's going to be moderated
by entrepreneur David Sachs.
But again,
the big news here
is that we are finally
getting confirmation from Governor
DeSantis, his team itself.
So much talk about this.
You all know,
for months and months and months now,
he is set to make this official
in a conversation
with the owner of Twitter, Elon Musk,
tomorrow night.
And then from there,
of course, launch
fully into
a presidential primary campaign
against a number of Republican rivals,
chief among them,
the former president, Donald Trump.
By Jessica,
a small percentage of the U.S.
population actually is active on Twitter.
Has the campaign explained
why this particular forum
for DeSantis,
his presidential announcement?
We haven't gotten any exact details on to
what as to why they chose it.
That is unique.
Jim, you make a great point in terms of
it's a very specific choice.
I do think that it is worth
remembering that Governor Ron
DeSantis and his team really look at this
as doing things their own way.
That's very important to them,
that they are kind of
doing things in a way that makes sense
for their candidate.
Governor DeSantis,
and that makes sense for his team.
And certainly this is a decision
they felt like was in line
with what they are
trying to achieve here.
And Jessica,
we understand from our reporting
that DeSantis was scheduled
to have a big event in Miami later
this week, getting together supporters
and bundlers, essentially folks
that are going to donate a lot of money
to his presidential campaign.
Do we have more details on this event
that Governor DeSantis is planning Right.
So I'm actually in Miami
right now as we speak, getting ready
to cover that event as well.
And what the campaign
or the once in future campaign
that will be launched tomorrow.
But his political operation
and the people supporting him
want to come out with a bang.
They really want to make an impression
with fundraising numbers,
with donors,
with the big name donors
and big totals
right out of the gate
to really make a big impression.
And that's what this is all about.
It's about getting all of these people
in one space
getting them all aligned
and making sure
that they are able to then begin
reaching out to their vast
network of donors
to really get
those political numbers up again.
You really only get one shot
at getting
into the presidential campaign,
and they want to make the most of this.
You can see that
this is
really what they've orchestrated in order
they hope to put him
as in strong opposition as possible
because he is getting in later
than the rivals, of course,
who have already gotten into the race.
Jessica, Dean, please stand by
as we await
more reporting
and more details about this
breaking news
that Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis is planning to announce a 20, 24
presidential campaign tomorrow night
in a conversation on Twitter Spaces
with billionaire entrepreneur Elon Musk.
We have David Chalian with us now, CNN's
chief political mind.
This this is a bit of a surprise,
isn't it?
I spoke to a Republican
just moments ago
who texted me that this movie supports
Ron DeSantis.
He says that this moves
this move captures
the zeitgeist of the right.
What do you make of that?
Well, remember,
Tucker Carlson just left
Fox News and said
Twitter is the only space in America
that allows for a free speech.
Kind of conversation.
So Ron DeSantis,
as we've seen time and again
in the last several months,
is in the build up to this
presidential campaign,
is making a hard play for that.
Activists, conservative, right
wing base,
Fox News, watching Tucker
loving kind of a thing.
This is part of that.
It's also going to a platform
that is not lost on any of us
that was dominated by Donald Trump
in American politics
for the last many years.
And clearly,
he wants to make a statement
with that as well.
We had heard from
Elon Musk last year
that he was supportive
of a DeSantis candidacy.
So this fits in
with a budding relationship
between these two gentlemen.
But this is going to be a multi-day
kind of rollout.
So this is one bite at the apple
to make it official.
Then he's going to have all his donors
in place
in Miami, start dialing for dollars,
get coverage of that.
Then following Memorial Day,
he may give
more of a traditional hometown
kind of speech in Florida
and then may
head out into early state travel
for the first time
as a presidential candidate,
all of which will get serious coverage
because in the polling, of course,
he has proven to be
the most serious contender
to Donald Trump
for the nomination, though
still a far way back
from devil's advocate for a moment here.
Twitter is a big space
for a certain portion,
but not a giant portion
of the population. Right.
And from a news perspective,
you cover the announcement.
You don't cover six chapters or access
to the announcement. Right. A bit.
Is it
is it one that has the broadest reach
for a presidential candidate in this day
and age?
Well, again, he's going to get coverage,
I think, at each stage of this
whether or not
it's like roadblock,
live coverage
on national cable television
or more local coverage,
as he does, though, stops
presidential candidates
on all different kinds
of earned media coverage.
Through the news media.
And I would imagine
that if indeed,
after this conversation on Twitter,
he were to give a big
formal announcement speech
that will get a lot of coverage to Jim
so I do think you are right to note
this is not.
This play is not to be
the widest reach possible.
This play to talk to Elon Musk on Twitter
and make it official,
there is to show allegiance
to a swath of the electorate
that that believes
after Tucker's departure from Fox
that what has happened with Elon
Musk inside of Twitter,
that this is a place for free speech
and will rally around that
whatever he does
is going to get picked up
and put out on other outlets
so he'll see that sort of broad reach,
even if on Twitter.
It's it is very narrow,
as Jim points out.
What's his pitch
going to be for that more broad appeal?
Well, I think he's made
as sort of a preview of two to the pitch
for the last several months,
which is this Florida blueprint
this ability to not, as he likes to say,
not just be a talker,
but be a doer to enact.
He has a supermajority
in the Florida legislature,
and he's used the last many months
to piece by piece
enact a conservative agenda
that he can take out
onto the campaign trail
and try to sell
the Republican primary electorate first
Remember, this is a two step process.
Ron DeSantis is looking to win
the Republican nomination first
and then on to,
he hopes, a general election.
But voters
remember things that happened
a few months ago. Right.
And for instance,
if you look at the abortion
ban in Florida,
that is a position
that even Republicans have noted to me
is one that makes it difficult
or will cause problems
in a general election
campaign, given
that it's more severe
than in other places.
So that is a risk for him
if he were to make it to that next day.
No doubt about it.
And you want proof of that.
He believes it may be a risk
politically also.
You'll recall
he signed that six week ban
sort of at night very hurriedly.
That didn't make a big splash about it.
He does not touted regularly.
He does before certain audiences.
And when Donald Trump said,
like you're saying, Jim, recently,
that some Republicans
call that too harsh,
he pushed back pretty aggressively
on that in defense of it.
So he doesn't shy away from it,
but he is aware
of the potential political risk there
because he doesn't wear it on his sleeve
like he does some of the other issues
that he put forth,
a frequent criticism of Ron
DeSantis very early on in the campaign
trail.
Again, we're talking about him
announcing tomorrow
he hasn't officially announced,
but we've seen him in Iowa.
We've seen him in New Hampshire.
And the feedback is
that he's not all that refined
when it comes to retail politics,
the one on one conversations.
Could he potentially change
that perception?
How much does that matter
going into this early primary stage?
I've observed
a lot of presidential candidates
on the campaign trail
get better at retail politics,
even if they don't
have an initial sort of
affinity for that.
In fact,
some of the reports
from his second New Hampshire
trip was a market improvement
from the first New Hampshire
trip on this. So we'll see.
This is part of,
you know, members of Congress
he served with when he was in the House
did not think of him as somebody
that was all that collegial or friendly
or you know,
so he this is definitely something
that I think observers and voters
will be watching on the campaign trail.
But I don't believe that's
the kind of thing that can't be improved.
I remember
a guy
named Barack Obama
who wasn't like all the greatest
in retail politics initially,
but he learned and got better
throughout his time on the trail.
He really did.
David Chalian, thank you so much.
And to Jessica Dean
as well for her quick reporting.
Thank you so much.